ready for this the greatest heavyweight
at boxing and mixed martial arts is not
in the UFC who the hell is pfl going to
get to fight Fran in MMA the answer is
nobody so again be cool pfl we can't
play grab ass and have him fight some
non nameer in pfl just get his rocks off
we're talking 30 m you can't afford my
boy now man DC said Barun Francis zanu
is the baddest man on the planet hands
down he ain't lying who's going to beat
him Jon Jones I'm on record saying I
thought JN would have smoked Francis
watching Francis vers Fury I'm like oh
he oh he beat John I think he beat John
MMA MMA whoa think he knocks him out I
didn't realize how good he was I knew he
was good he's the heavyweight champion I
didn't realize he was this God talented
I knew he was a freak athletically I
didn't know he was world class boxing
beat the greatest of all time good who
did this is not